-Thank you very much for
watching "The Tonight Show,"
everybody. I appreciate it.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys.
Bob Woodward has a new book
coming out about the President,
and one story is making
major headlines today.
It turns out Trump knew
way back in early February
how bad the coronavirus was,
but he continued to downplay it
to the American people.
And Woodward's
got it all on tape
because Trump let him
record their conversations.
Check this out.
Here's Trump in mid-March.
Yeah. I remember Americans
not panicking when they spent
thousands for a roll
of toilet paper on eBay.
Seriously. You didn't
want to create a panic?
For the last six months,
I've been opening doorknobs
with my knees.
How could he downplay this?
He's treated the pandemic
like those flash-flood alerts
on your phone.
Like, "Eh.
I'm sure it's nothing.
Never heard this phone
make that sound before, though."
Yeah, it's a catastrophic
story for Trump
that threatens
to end his presidency,
or, as he calls it, Wednesday.
These tapes are insane.
Here's Trump talking about
the virus in early February.
Listen to this.
Up until then, Trump thought
"deadly stuff"
was a brand of Oreos.
Meanwhile, Trump heard
the recording and was like,
"I never met that guy.
I don't know who he is."
Seriously,
these tapes are really bad.
Trump's reelection prospects
are sinking faster
than a boat at a MAGA rally.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm being too critical.
Before I pass judgment,
I should read the other
40 Trump books
that came out this week.
And despite Trump saying
as recently as last month
that kids are almost immune
from the virus,
it turns out he knew
that wasn't the truth
all the way back in March.
Check out this clip.
I'd say at this point
the dude needs to give HIMSELF
some hush money.
[ Laughter ]
Is he serious?
He knew all that and still
fought for schools to reopen?
Even Vladimir Putin was like,
"Not cool, dude. Not cool."
Now, despite what the numerous
tell-all books say about him,
Trump received a pretty
surprising nomination today.
-President Trump
has been nominated
for the 2021 Nobel Peace Prize.
Here's how --
a far-right Norwegian lawmaker
is telling news outlets he
submitted the President's name
to the committee
for the President's work
on that agreement
between Israel and the UAE.
[ Laughter ]
-In response, Trump was like,
"How do you say 'vote twice'
in Norwegian?"
"Vottka-tuug."
Yeah, Trump thinks
he's getting the Peace Prize
for uniting Americans
and the coronavirus.
Meanwhile, Trump is focused
on the upcoming election,
and last night,
he delivered a campaign speech
in North Carolina.
At one point,
he mentioned Kamala Harris,
and here's what
he had to say about her.
-You know what?
People don't like her.
Nobody likes her.
She could never be
the first woman president.
She could never be.
[ Crowd jeering ]
That would be an insult
to our country.
-Mike Pence was like,
"Hey, cool it, man.
Some of us has to
debate her next month."
I wonder what Trump thinks is so
insulting about Kamala Harris.
I feel like the answer
is white in front of me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like,
"She's so unpopular,
her approval rating is barely
20 points higher than mine."
Later on in his speech,
Trump mentioned something
he used to talk about
all the time.
Check it out.
-And you know
Mexico is paying for the wall,
just so you understand,
but we're going to charge them
a small fee at the border.
You know, the toll booths.
We have toll booths.
And we're gonna get all the
money that we spent on the wall
will be coming back.
So, remember I used to say,
"Who's going to pay for it?"
They'd say, "Mexico."
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-And then Trump announced
a new branch of the military,
the Toll Booth Force.
They all would say --
They always would say that.
I would say, "Who's gonna --"
They said, "Who's gonna pay?"
And they all would say.
That sounds like
an interesting idea.
Our borders will be protected
by a giant wall
and that little toll-booth arm
that goes up and down.
No problem.
Here's some big
entertainment news
that caught a lot of people
by surprise. Listen to this.
-Season 20 of "Keeping Up
with the Kardashians"
will be its last.
The show has run on E!
for the past 14 years,
following Kim, Khloé, Kourtney,
Kris, and the whole crew
as they went about
their daily lives.
-Wow.
It's a tough blow for fans
who will now only be able
to keep up with the family
through Instagram,
TikTok, Twitter, tabloids,
and the Internet.
Right now all the executives
at the E! Network are like,
"So...how are we gonna fill
20 hours a day?"
Well, guys, as if these
aren't scary enough times,
listen to what happened
earlier today in New Jersey.
-The magnitude-3.1 earthquake
reported in New Jersey.
According to the
U.S. Geological Survey,
it was centered
near East Freehold.
-That's right. There was an
earthquake in New Jersey.
It was crazy. There were
track suits thrown everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
The entire state
looked like every TJ Maxx.
It was a pretty decent
earthquake.
Scientists in Jersey
gave it 3 out of 10 "Ohhhhh's!"
Well, here's some
interesting news.
The U.S. Air Force is testing
out a new kind of technology --
robot dogs.
Check this out.
[ Menacing music plays ]
♪♪
I hope the robot dogs work,
otherwise, we're going to be
seeing a lot of Sarah McLachlan
robot-dog commercials.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Illinois
celebrated his 100th birthday
in an exciting way.
Watch this.
-An Illinois man
celebrating his 100th birthday
by breaking a wet and wild
world record.
Bill Lambert became
the world's oldest scuba diver
by taking a plunge
in Pearl Lake.
He says his goal
is to stay in shape
and break it again
when he turns 101.
-Actually, it wasn't
that hard for him.
He's been carrying around
an oxygen tank for years.
[ Laughter ]
It was an unforgettable day
for him...and also the deck hand
who had to help him
into his wet suit.